hello and welcome to this video playing
p ed or pet from denmark well I've got
seven out of seven against them let's
keep keep it like that yeah the exchange
variation not exactly one of my favorite
lines it's difficult to generate any
interesting play so okay here at least
is this kind of interesting so how am i
playing this may be here right to
provoke f3 no it just drains okay that
should be very dangerous for black right
okay a knight to e5 and you wants to
play these three here
95 204 than something nice if I can get
it in okay let's grab some space if he
invites me with 83 m I'm also opening up
the G file okay wants to go nitey for
here okay so no no okay I thought 94 I
rather wants to trade everything here
thats that's his idea 94 may be coming
to prepare c5
yes you five to take away some central
squares
check check well he really was just
wants to trade everything down and try
to hold this end game okay
bring up the king I 9594 a threatening
note g5 hmm
94 was an issue okay so what to do here
it's still not easy easy to imply for
win in this position an exchange
variation is really remarkably solid and
what can even play a couple of
second-rate moves like in this game and
still it's not like downright losing or
anything okay so what to do here
and pawn this week really this week
still don't think I should be in big
trouble but yeah getting this getting
this is pretty awful out of this opening
my black was just having the bishop pair
for nothing
okay still hard to see him play now okay
yeah bishop see one it's still a pretty
good Bishop pam d for less Bishop e3
it's still not easy home to play I will
win one of the ponds and ce4 is weak on
top so
ok goes all the way back there be three
I've got a five fixing the pawns
yeah so from a pawn down it went up to
being a pawn up right at five it's not
very nice let's pin prevent that or at
least delay it for some time
yeah ticking it's not enough I guess
yeah bye I ponder us are not so great
here right with the double porn night f7
yeah I guess I centralized this and now
we're going back or to see one time
worry I got to see one h.samuel are
still have covered I can take here what
check
and now my a pawn please okay I it's got
two seconds or something like what yeah
I have supplied that badly this is just
this should be excellent simply without
any problems or whatever my king support
structure is a bit weak but still check
that was just that wasn't really good I
have to be more precise from here this
ok and now hear this he just thought he
just has this after which I have to take
I guess here now he only wife can be
better but my active King should
probably ensure that I'm not losing keep
this and I have no idea to be honest I
don't think I can't be worse here that's
it's very hard to believe I should
always be active enough h4 is some no
care for a job I can take on air for of
course but I wanted wanted to try more
try for more and here the computer wants
to play Bishop to eat five and just try
to be more precise probably try to win
the pawn with the king this is what the
engine is giving see 3 yeah okay you
probably have to do something like that
and draw it should be a draw should be
it wrong yeah and that's it wrong and
here I'm I'm better
the two bishops are really awful awful
to play against Joe yeah I'm happy with
the last like 20 moves of the game that
was was ok always keeping keeping
pressure up and not giving away anything
much it was totally fine but late
opening hmm not so sure ok thanks for
watching